plus
l'actualité en france maintenant et
devant le tribunal correctionnel de caen
de monseigneur piquant a reconnu qu'il
avait fait une importante erreur
d'appréciation
l'évêque de bayeux n'avait pas dénoncé à
la justice l'abbé bissey elle
responsable d'actes de pédophilie
aujourd'hui il s'en repent mais risque
trois ans de prison pour un silence
coupable sur place nathalie cause et de
nos villes
monseigneur piquant explique qu'il
assume son silence avec une réelle
souffrance il comparaît aujourd'hui
devant le tribunal correctionnel de caen
pour non dénonciation d'atteintes
sexuelles sur mineures informé en 96 des
actes pédophiles du père bis lévesque se
tait un silence insupportable pour les
victimes submergé par l'émotion ludovic
elle ce matin un malaise c'est lui qui a
finalement alerté la justice en 98
aujourd'hui c'est le procès de monsieur
picot c'est lui qui n'a pas eu la prise
de conscience pour dénoncer cet individu
qui a fait un véritable carnage
parmi les victimes ce prêtre s'est
constituée partie civile contre
monseigneur piquant il n'admet pas que
le permis c était et renommé en paroisse
après quelques mois de soins
et de paroisses pour connor m on aurait
pu ne pas nommer d'autres ailleurs c'est
tout simplement ça et ça porte à notre
crédibilité
longuement interrogé cet après midi
l'évêque répète qu'il ne pouvait pas
trahir le permis c'est qu'ils étaient
soumis au secret professionnel
mais la loi impose aussi la dimension
des sévices sur enfants souligné le
président lui avez-vous demandé de se
dénoncer je lui en ai parlé mais je ne
lui pas imposer répond monseigneur
piquant l'avocat des victimes insiste
aujourd'hui le dénonce riez vous non
répond lévesque parce que l'évêque n'est
pas le substitut du procureur de la
république les mecs mais pas un flic les
vins qui est un pasteur lévesque est en
charge il responsabilité d'église
contrairement à ce qu'on croit lorsque
on on reçoit des propos qu'il est
difficile malaisé interdit de divulguer
selon les cas on ne couvre pas une zone
de non droit il y à mille et une
manières d'agir concrètement
le procureur rappelle à monseigneur
picon que depuis 96 la société a changé
par rapport à la pédophilie et vous
demande-t-il oui beaucoup de choses en
moi ont changé avez-vous commis une
grave erreur de jugement avec le père
lycée c'était une importante erreur
d'appréciation répond l'évêque clown